[Music]
to reach net zero electricity grids all
over the world need to be powered by low
carbon sources
wind and solar power is producing more
electricity every year
but their output is patchy and doesn't
always match demand
however there is a more reliable option
[Music]
it's hard to think of anything more
important to all of our futures than
reducing carbon emissions it's a big job
and it needs to be done quickly if we're
going to avoid the consequences of
catastrophic global warming and climate
change hal i know you've been writing
about uh where we are with nuclear power
what's preventing this from building
loads of nuclear plants to to take up
the slack here uh is the problem mainly
technical is it mainly economic nuclear
power would be a lovely thing to have a
lot of right it's you know it's
incredibly uh low carbon it's just as
low carbon as solar panels and wind
farms once you take into account
building the things and making all of
the stuff that goes into them
it's incredibly safe compared to all of
the fossil fuels
because it doesn't emit particulate
pollution which causes respiratory
disease ostensibly very very useful form
of clean carbon free and firm very
important power that doesn't change if
you look at the british grid it's got
lots and lots of wind on it
and it's got gas and it's got nuclear
and the supply lines from winds are
crazy they go up and down and up and
down all the time um the supply line
from nuclear is just like a calm serene
flat line in comparison
and you know this tells you everything
you need to know about what the grid
needs
the problem is both of the things you
said it is both
in the west at least in countries like
the united kingdom in america france
uh
basically we've lost the ability to
build them we haven't built any of them
for such a long time most countries have
gone sort of 20 or 30 years since they
last started building one the the supply
chains the skills the people are just
crafty they're not they're not up to
scratch they're not used to building
these things and this means that when
you start building one it's very slow
and it's very painful and when you need
to be
loaned a lot of money for a thing that
you're kind of like well i don't know
when exactly i can start paying you back
maybe it'll be in five years maybe it'll
be in eight years it could be 12 years
or it could in the case of something
like akuloto which is the finnish
nuclear power plant that is still not
finished despite being started in 2005
it could be like almost 20 years the
other thing about nuclear plants of
course is that they're incredibly highly
regulated because they have to be
because you know everyone's worried that
something dangerous will happen that
there'll be a meltdown we've also got
people asking what about nuclear waste
where does that fit into the um the
drawbacks of um of this nuclear waste is
obviously very potent stuff but there's
a few things to say about it that are
really important one is that just in
terms of volume it's incredibly tiny all
of the nuclear waste that the planet has
produced so far in 50 years 60 years of
running nuclear power plants is enough
to fill one football field by about six
feet and that might sound like a lot but
if you think about the whole planet it's
absolutely tiny the amount of coal
tailings like basically the ash from the
bottom of a coal power plant is just
stupendously gigantically more enormous
than that and in many cases waste from
coal power plants is as radioactive as
waste for nuclear power plants but
there's much fewer regulations about it
you know you've got cases like in
tennessee where a big coal tailings pond
just collapses and all of it flows into
a river and everyone's like oh oh well
if that was nuclear waste we'd all be
absolutely freaking out um
and
the the storage of this stuff is
it's not a solved problem but one one
place in the world is very far ahead and
it's finland and they have built a huge
deep cave uh into which this stuff gets
put not in a kind of homer simpson
pouring some green sludge into a pit way
but in a
basically what you do is you take the
waste you vitrify it which means you
turn it into glass then you put it in a
specially made barrel that is made out
of concrete you slosh it into these
specially made slots then you bury the
barrel of concrete in a big hole in the
ground with a bunch more concrete all of
this happens hundreds of feet
underground in a stone cave and when you
filled up all of these slots in the
floor with barrels and barrels of waste
you seal it over forever and it's gone
and the fins in very finished style say
they don't want any signage up at the
top of the cave saying watch out there's
nuclear waste here because one of the
sort of interesting long-term
discussions is how do you warn future
people don't don't go here the finns
have taken the approach of we're just
going to say nothing and assume that no
one will ever find this thing uh which
is which which is an interesting
approach but basically you know there's
lots of components to it but the waste
issue there are many many more important
things not least uh you know warming up
the planet and making it unlivable
hello i'm tom standage deputy editor at
the economist if you'd like to learn
more about this topic click on the link
opposite thanks for watching and don't
forget to subscribe
[Music]